[Music]
over the course of the 1960's the FBI
amassed almost 2,000 documents in an
investigation into one of America's most
celebrated minds the subject of this
inquiry was a writer named James Baldwin
at the time the FBI investigated many
artists and thinkers but most of their
files were a fraction of the size of
Baldwin's during the years when the FBI
hounded him he became one of the
best-selling black authors in the world
so what made James Baldwin looms so
large in the imaginations of both the
public and the authorities born in
Harlem in 1924 he was the oldest of nine
children at age fourteen he began to
work as a preacher by delivering sermons
he developed his voice as a writer but
also grew conflicted about the Church's
stance on racial inequality and
homosexuality after high school he began
writing novels and essays while taking a
series of odd jobs but the issues that
had driven him away from the church were
still inescapable in his daily life
constantly confronted with racism and
homophobia he was angry and
disillusioned and yearned for a less
restricted life so in 1948 at the age of
24 he moved to Paris on a writing
fellowship from France he published his
first novel go tell it on the mountain
in 1953 set in Harlem the book explores
the church as a source of both
repression and hope it was popular with
both black and white readers as he
earned acclaim for his fiction Baldwin
gathered his thoughts on race class
culture and exile in his 1955 extended
essay notes of a native son meanwhile
the civil rights movement was gaining
momentum in America black Americans were
making incremental gains at registering
to vote and voting but were still denied
basic dignities in schools on buses in
the workforce and in the armed services
though he lived primarily in France for
the rest of his life Baldwin was deeply
invested in the movement and keenly
aware of his country's unfulfilled
promise he had seen family friends and
neighbors spiral into addiction
incarceration and suicide he believed
their fates originated from the
constraints of a segregated society in
1963 he published the fire next time an
arresting portrait of racial strife in
which he held white America accountable
but he also went further arguing that
racism hurt white people too in his view
everyone was inextricably and meshed in
the same social fabric
he had long believed that people are
trapped in history and history is
trapped in them Baldwin's role in the
civil rights movement went beyond
observing and reporting he also traveled
through the American South attending
rallies giving lectures of his own he
debated both white politicians and black
activists including Malcolm X and served
as a liaison between black activists and
intellectuals and white establishment
leaders like Robert Kennedy because of
Baldwin's unique ability to articulate
the causes of social turbulence in a way
that white audiences were willing to
hear
Kennedy and others tended to see him as
an ambassador for black Americans a
label Baldwin rejected and at the same
time his faculty with words led the FBI
to view him as a threat even within the
civil rights movement Baldwin could
sometimes feel like an outsider for his
choice to live abroad as well as the
sexuality which he explored openly in
his writing at a time when homophobia
ran rampant throughout his life
Baldwin considered it his role to bear
witness unlike many of his peers he
lived to see some of the victories of
the civil rights movement but the
continuing racial inequalities in the
United States weighed heavily on him
though he may have felt trapped in his
moment in
Street his words have made generations
of people feel known while guiding them
toward a more nuanced understanding of
society's most complex issues
[Music]
learn about other Trailblazers of the
civil rights movement with these videos